hello
welcome to another night of just on
psychology well
first night of 2021 psychology i was
pretty sure i would say the day drunk so
that i take that as a small personal
achievement
um hopefully everybody is having a great
start of the year
um i don't really have much news to say
besides
struggling with scheduling the mcat and
just trying to figure out
when to study how to study trying to
keep the room clean
that one is not really going well i
still have to adjust a lot on that
and um yeah a lot of things going on you
guys will be seeing a lot more of me
until 20th and then i will probably have
to step back and just
focus more on studying because it's
gonna get really rough
my it's i'll tell you more about it
as we are talking about the game when i
take
a little pause we will talk about that a
little bit more oh
i see a lot of a lot of my regulars are
here peter
elvis oh me diary slap all right
awesome so this is one of my most
favorite games
when it comes to lopez last time
last week well we talked a lot about me
playing
lopez from black and i
i know that we talked about lopez's
white
a while ago over the summer i want to
say
and from white we had a different
perspective because
i was recommending this line with queen
e2
and i'm sure we can find the link on
youtube to put it here as well later on
but my um from black we don't
we never really covered it and gmp she's
also
um sharing his satisfactions
yeah peachy is meowing at the stray cat
again i fed him
for her just before i went live
alright so let's go ahead and get
started um
if there are any um indians here
or you might well you would most likely
know rudmini
if not she's a very famous chess player
she's a very strong
i believe she's on india's national team
for women so
um if you know her you're gonna really
like this game even if you don't know
her you're still gonna like this game
so sure what's up elvis
ah peter yeah i don't know i sometimes i
open the door a little bit
and the stray cat comes in for a little
bit and just
warms up and then he goes out again so i
don't really know what's his deal but
he kind of somewhat trusts me but he
wouldn't eat from my hand
but like he would come very close and he
meows at me so
i think we got a good um good
uh relationship going on with the stray
cats
but no i wouldn't let the other cat get
close to my cat
even though he's vaccinated and
everything anyways cat
cat loan problems um
well alice we are not focusing too much
on the opening of it but i am advocating
for
this line uh either with e either with
a6
um knight f6 or
the generally doing the fiance in this
line
i i do advocates for that and that's
something that i talked about
last week so i wanted to show you a
little bit
different a little different way that i
went for this game
and um so this game i didn't actually go
for this
g6 lopez because i usually go for either
g6 or d6
and i'm kind of a big fan on these ones
and these ideas with knight e7 i just
generally
like this however um
well that's also another good thing that
does somewhat transpose
from the kings indian if you were to
play it
but this game is i'm showing it's more
because of the tactics that
were included in this game not
necessarily the opening of it
because i also ran out of the opening
ideas pretty quickly anyways
i also can't believe this game was over
five years ago
i feel old yeah
this was in 2015 qatar masters
and i had a lot of fun in that
tournament i played a lot of good games
but it was like i was um
i think it was one of the first
tournaments that
i was um traveling alone without my mom
and i was kind of interesting
but i also really didn't enjoy cats i
was very
humid but anyways that's a whole
different story
um oh and i think i was like literally
the last rank
or one before last because the
tournament was 2300 above
and i was barely above 20 hundred 300 so
that was that that way that's a lot more
fun
i felt like a punching bag
okay so here this
is not really um this is not necessarily
the main
choice of playing you know people
usually get this bishop out right
i went for b5 and i got bishop b7 first
because i was slightly hopeful i could
get this bishop out from g7
and i didn't because my opponent was a
very strong
uh chess player and she knew what she
was doing and everything
and i had this line very little prepared
because
i expected other i expected her to play
other stuff
and everything but uh generally
i wouldn't exactly advocate for this a65
and i'm the reason i'm actually showing
you this opening is because how easily
you can get busted in the opening and i
almost did get busted
and then i pulled some tactics out and
it looks pretty cool
but um anyways so
let's just take a quick moment and
evaluate this position
so black to move well one thing that's
obvious is we're not gonna do
long castle we're definitely gonna go
short castle so
now the question is what do you want to
do with this bishop
um so i was i don't exactly base my
decisions on the opponent's rating
well the more i can prepare for the
opponent the better so
before the game i would know my
opponents and for
most tournaments and i would simply look
them up on
the chess-based database or mega or well
back when there's just tv now there's
not
and um i would look at their games and i
would try to make a decision on
the things that they usually play and so
what would i
play against that so i i am quite proud
of my preparations
generally so
huh i see that lopez zippo
yeah there are a lot of things uh
possible to do with this bishop
um this should be seven or bishop c5 are
the most common ones
i wouldn't advocate for g6 because this
knight g5 can actually get very nasty
um i'm one move short if i if my bishop
was already on g7 i could lancaster that
would be good but
uh g6 wouldn't work now and something
like h6
is too slow because then knight gets up
at night's coming to d5 i can't i just
don't have enough time
and white's pieces are more ready
so that's one of the reasons this would
not be working
this idea with g6 so at this point i was
like
okay so juices is not working i should
either go bishop v7
or i should go um bishop
bishop to c5 so which one do you guys
think we should do
i see that there are a lot of a lot of
they're like a mix of
um both ideas in the chat so
um i went for bishop e7 my reasoning was
well just because with bishop c files i
didn't know what to expect
i rarely play this bishop c5s when it
comes to lopez because i
generally place my bishop on g7 so to me
bishop c5 was an uncomfortable move just
mainly because i didn't know
where was i placing my pieces after that
i was like okay if my c3
castle there could be bishop g5 and then
what am i gonna do maybe h6
and maybe i gotta bring this back it
felt very unnatural to me
so i didn't go for it i went for bishop
v7 i do i will give you a heads up
much much later in the game i did
replace my bishop
back in this diagonal which i thought
was kind of cool
so um bishop a7 yeah yeah another
problem bishop c5 was this idea of c3d42
just a lot of things to watch out for
with when the bishop is on c5
so i think we went for visual e7 now um
rook did this knight c3
now how do you think we should develop
well
the first um the next two moves could
simply be d6 on
short castle but my question is
what what after that what are you trying
to achieve after that
um always that expansion on the king
side
is something that you should consider
but the best way to do it
is when your opponent center is closed
closed
so if you have your pawn on d6 your
opponent has his pawn on d5
that's when it would go best when we are
doing that um when we are closing up the
center a little bit
so yeah that's a little um that's one of
the things that's
a little tricky
so yeah i agree okay yourself you got
this yeah
uh i agree with this first two moves and
the idea of moving this knight to being
able to do c5
that's what i wanted to hear yeah so
d6 in the game she played a4 now what do
you think we should do after this a4
yes a4 feels a little unnatural and we
should face it we should do something
about it we shouldn't just
sit and watch it
and i have a meow and cat
oh boy
so one thing is for sure we shouldn't
take it you're gonna have two choices
either push it or do something with like
knight a5 to try and go for that guy
uh-oh maybe it's time for gmp to be
hugged and squished
all right so i see that the you guys are
trying to figure out which one to go for
i kind of like that so i think d4 is
definitely doable
my issue with b4 was that um
with e4 i can't um
i have to be able to actually figure out
what to do next as in sensor
well if you go knight to e2 i'm kind of
pushing your knight towards this f5
square which i have no protection for
so that's something that i would have to
actually deal with and
it was very unnatural to me
and the other part about b4 was this
knight d5
so i'm what would you guys want to do
would you want to take it would you not
want to take it if you don't take it
then your bishop on e7 is under pressure
if you do take it
then the bishop can take it now this is
another pen
and it all feels a lot um
a little uncomfortable a little more
uncomfortable than i
intended so yeah let's just go
back and look at that
so i chose not to go for b4 i thought my
t5 was a little bit more stable
if you were to take this awesome i'll
just take that i'll mess with your pawn
structure a little bit now good luck
with these palms
take i can simply take over here now
that's another thing that i'm going to
be happy about
i can simply just ignore your knight
over here
go for device it's going to be very
interesting
i agree no no the patient needs a little
bit of squishing it's that time
yeah so i liked my idea with 95
my opponent she's smart she's a strong
chess player she played bishop way too
now what do you guys think we should do
now
so we did this one small kick now what
yeah peach is not very happy about this
i'm not entirely sure why
oh castle i um please feel free to
refresh my memory where have we met
yeah i i did call uh yep she's literally
cat and farsi
i like it let's push pawn yep um i'm
hoping you guys are talking about d4
right because if you wear if you go c5
your pawn is
falling so be careful a little bit with
that
um all right
so uh b4 is actually a very good idea
that is what i went for too
now it goes to e2 the thing is now my
default does
i mean this is still exists it's not an
illegal rule
but after take pawn tanks and
um it feels more stable because yes you
could take with bishop
but then after this exchange um i still
can just simply do c5
and if even if you do the ambassador now
my knight is coming back i
have potential to take over center and
it just feels
much much more natural and much more
planned than other positions
so yeah that's one that could be
doable too and if you take with pawn i
think
c5 still very much exists b3 looks kind
of cool
all right um
so in the game she played knight e2
now what do you think we should do uh
ryan i
i don't know i have very mixed feelings
about it i feel like if
i prepare for it i would like it but if
i just go out on a women place
i will get punished so mixed feelings
i guess my meal scared the cats nice
so what do you guys think about this one
oh c5 interesting um so i think the
choice is kind of between should we
castle now or should we move
some pawns because i'm getting the idea
with c5 and d5 and stuff like that
i think castle is a little bit more
stable
because uh as i see also in the chat
there is a um i don't want to say
confusion maybe
a debate between whether we want pawn to
be on c5 or do we want to play c6 d5
so mainly because we don't exactly know
about that
it would be beneficial to do castle
because we know we want to do castle so
let's do the castle and
we'll see where we want to place this
pawn
so after castle
knight g3 very normal going after f5
square
so we're not going to uh
play something like g6 because that kind
of stops it well that does stop it
but that also gives your king lots and
lots of weaknesses and your bishop would
be better if it was on g7 if you were
gonna play
g6 so we are not gonna play g6
so how else can we fight this knight d5
and okay i should probably stop gushing
over the cat but he's sitting
right here like literally behind the
laptop and staring at me
there is a small possibility that he
will walk into the microphone so i
apologize in advance for that
as a prophylaxis i apologize croc
prophylaxis apology so
[Music]
you know cute enough but it can be
a little cutie right all right um
so uh cancer i
well queen d7 or quincy it doesn't
really
help you because well it still might
come to five and you can't really take
it
bishop c doesn't make much sense anyways
because
we're like um the problem with bishop c8
is you can just do d4
so that's also a little cringy
um if you have to play bishop c8 you
shouldn't play bishop c just play c5 and
fight that way
and uh yeah kitty for galaxy
so you have another choice too
um
hi guys what do you guys think about d5
and yes i know this pawn is falling at
least being under attack
so just asking your opinion i'm not
saying if this is a good or bad
just asking opinion
all right i see one like one dislike
a bunch of people probably still
processing it
well we are going to open up the center
that's not the idea one of the ways to
fight this idea with knight f5
is to go for d5 but the question is does
it work here
um if take yes we could simply take it
back with
knight or bishop uh i think bishop might
be a little bit more feisty
because if you take on e4 now i can take
and there's this cool queen d5
i've been doing a lot of puzzles with my
kids so
this would actually work would be pretty
cool
um one more way to look at it
is this ideas of like rookie one and you
could take take and play bishop d6 if
you take over here
now you would still have some ideas
because like a lot of places a lot of
pieces are misplaced
but overall i agree d5 is not the best
move the best move in this position is
actually
c5 and that's something that i didn't
feel comfortable about over the game and
i wanted to play feisty and i wanted to
kind of give my opponent a little like
scratch and hiss and
see how that goes but it went pretty
well actually
but c5 is the best way to go i was
afraid of knight f5
but i shouldn't have because now i could
just play all right well we can just go
to a king h8
and we could think about that or now we
could go like
something bishop c8 it's not as
comfortable as
i would hope but it's still very much
doable
i can even like try to um
move more pieces around try to go for
that
so yeah that was one thing that i could
do
um okay so
let's let's go back back back
uh here after going for d5
and queen e2 was played again
knight e5 so what do you guys think what
happens if my opponent
took this knight takes e5 right away
because that's something that's very
doable
and it's kind of a scary one too so you
kind of kind of have to know what you're
doing
[Music]
uh
[Music]
i apologize for your ears hopefully the
prophylaxis apology was enough
to give a little bit of heads up
all right let me grab the cat he's being
a little
how you doing boy
oh ben simon calling me
probably i should pick up
what's up ben hey is everything okay
um the pc was um facing the microphone
i moved the cat and i moved the
microphone away from the cat
i apologize for your ears
oh god i gotta go watch that clip later
yes we're fine thank you for checking
thanks
yeah that was fun so that that was uh
that was uh
my producer ben simon calling to make
sure i'm alive and appreciated not to
kill me with that sound
i hope your ears are fine everybody else
i did give a small heads up and i did
i did have a prophylaxis apology all
right
so we were just talking about this
position and
how um if d5 was a good idea
and my point was um
d5 was a good
fighting option but not the best one and
the best one was c5
um the main problem with d5 is
knight takes e5 and if you were to take
and uh take would be fine but the
problem is knight f5 and you see these
knights are getting really wild
or even d4 that's also another issue
so yeah that's something to figure out
and um so that's why d5 was not the best
choice
root simply played queen e2 which was
another good idea wants to play rook d1
wants to do everything strategically and
correctly
now what do you think we should do as
black we have few choices
most of our choices should be regarded
of keeping this pawn alive because that
pawn is about to
be a gonzo so what do you think we
should do
oh wait that's tracy
oh okay well i put
hmm now that's a little tricky why is
tracy behind here
not that i'm complaining trace is a dull
um okay so i've seen your ideas with
bishop d6
but the the problem is if you play
bishop d6 bishop g5 is coming up and
white does have
uh advantage so you gotta be a little
careful about that
another thing is if bishop d6
um thinking no taking doesn't really
sound correct because you then you would
have b3 and then you would activate this
that's why i absolutely love having this
knight and this pawn here because it
always gives me this
cute b3 ideas bishop d6 problem is
bishop g5
and even if you were to take it now
knight takes it and there's more
pressure and
and doesn't really go well uh
again similar idea with my c6 now knight
f5
that's again serious issue
um 97 uh he can just easily eat this
pawn
and again this pawn is a kind of getting
punished too
so i think you have uh logically few
choices one of them is b3 i think b3 is
a pretty cool idea because if you were
to take it now this knight c6 is pretty
cool
because knight can jump around a little
bit and
everything is somewhat defended so i
think
b3 was the best idea i went for take
my point was if you take it now i can do
bishop d6
now can you tell me if this works or not
so now it's white too
what do you think white can do to bring
some pain
basically
all right so i see a lot of interesting
ideas going around but
um knight f5 bishop g5
i see those that are very interesting
uh rook d1 yeah rook t1 is the best and
most simple way to go because
you did this queen d2 to do district d1
so let's go ahead and do that
um queen c4 doesn't really um
serve a purpose and also a little tiny
bit of blunder
i would love queen c4 as black
um so after rook d1 now what do you
think we should do as
black because you are facing some
serious issues
this pawn is falling for for beginning
um you you could consider something like
queening eight but then bishop goes to
g5
you move this then knight goes to f5
everything
is just attacking you um
and it's really it doesn't it's just not
gonna
you're not gonna be able to really hold
it so
that's for queenie queen e7 i assume
similar ideas with either knight f5
first or bishop g5 first
so white's next two move are bishop g
whoops basically bishop g5 and lights f5
so the question is how are you going
to be able to fight that
and um knight c6 is
is a legit possibility
but after bishop g5 again h6 bishop goes
away and this pen
really doesn't stay so um
to put it very bluntly
black is a little bit um
having issues for in this position
there's one pin over here there's
another pin
right around the corner this square is
just crying
so yeah this pond is also another
crybaby so good luck
um in the game i just wanted to find
something that would give me some chance
of fighting
so here black is worse
saying it loud i'm proud i had a worse
position against a stronger opponent but
i managed to find some tricks and win it
so now we're trying to figure out how
well in the game i went through a king
of shades
my point was if you come bishop g5 now
i'm gonna try and kick this bishop away
a little
maybe i could do like a cute g5 maybe i
could do like a rook g8 g5 i could just
do something because i don't want to sit
there and just get mated
so that was kind of my general idea
um in the game she played bishop
d2 uh because she wants to eat this pond
right
free pond why not now black to move what
do you think we should do whoops
this move bishop d2 was an inaccuracy
best move for white was to still go for
bishop g5
and then i would probably have to do
like a h6 and do like a b3
kick that one then try to maybe bring
this knight around a little
but white still does hold a considerable
advantage
so bishop g5 was the way to go she made
a mistake with bishop d2
now the question is how are we going to
um
well survive this basically
all right i see there are some ideas
with knight c6 i see some
ideas with b3 i think the problem with
b3 right now
is also bishop takes a5 and that's
not really ideal um
so that's a little sad oh hi exquisite
how's it going
um yeah so in the game i just went for
queen e8 and i was like okay so let's
get this queen away from this pen
let's save this bishop from being
overloaded and being pinned
and i was okay and i was like okay so i
know my position is worse
but at least it's not as horrible as i
thought
uh there's a question about knight e5 so
what do you guys think
knight e5 um well i shouldn't ask if i
was actually decent move
uh the problem with knight t5 was queen
e7 and going after this guy so now when
you move it i still have
something taking on e4
and it's still very much playable
there's not
nothing really wrong with it but at the
same time
white wanted to gain more that's why
this was not why it's going um
that's that was not exactly white's
first choice
oh thank you exquisite yeah i'm a little
uh sad that it's
super duper cold here but it doesn't
snow
so i made it snow basically
yeah um so after bishop d2 queen eight
to just avoid all
bunch of pins and she uh
played now she played bishop g5 so she
kind of realized that oh
probably i should have you know gone for
this pawn earlier
i'm sorry for this pin earlier
now what black to move what do you think
you should do
and to be fair these are kind of sucky
positions
so if you can't really um find the best
move
it's not because well it's mainly most
likely because
the best moves are kind of weird so
don't feel bad about it
and my ipad is acting up a little bit
just a second let me
load back youtube all right
oh my oh well that's that's nice
keep keep calming princess leia what
what what
well what would pg be in that situation
yeah you're actually great xl uh and
pablo
knight's g8 was the best move and
i was very strong stubborn to do this
uh nigerians would be a good choice
because
then uh after knight f5 i could just try
to save this bishop put this bishop in a
slightly better place
try to bring back the knights try to you
know do it like at f6
i guess pc agrees too um but i was very
stubborn and i really did not want to
play the slide g8
so i was very scared of knight f5 at the
same time so i just went for bishop c8
and i was somewhat fine with take
which did happen in the game and then
bishop d5 so
now what to do
yeah my g8 would have been a smart
choice
smarter joints i think 98 would simply
um give it a little bit more
uh room i didn't like how
it would just like resign in the
activity
department but
that was kind of the idea to want to
bring it back but there wasn't enough
time and this
knight had ideas with b3 well no longer
but so the it was there wasn't really
enough time
and here again the problem is c6 doesn't
exactly work because simply take and
then take on d6 yeah
nice so i kind of had to um
know what i was doing and i went for
rook b8 i was like okay
district defending this pawn we'll see
how that goes for a little bit
uh knight h4 going after this guy
so you know you have a worse position
you know your opponent has
somewhat advantage but it's you're not
completely dead so you just have to be
able to put up a good fight so
how can you put up this good fight so my
question is
you know the situation what do you think
what plan could you come up with
because if you could come up with a plan
that could somewhat help you
and you should always have a plan when
you are playing chess
hmm
all right so i'm seeing a lot of ideas
with bishop v6 or
knight c6 but
rook g8 seems more um
legit
yeah because rook g8 is uh making it
harder for it to work because
with rook g8 now uh trying to at least
get
like a bishop g4 out um
so richard somewhat maybe now knight
comes to f5 now what
attacking your bishop
foreign
pc
um bishop c5 interesting but careful
knight h6 is coming
up so you kind of have to go bishop with
eight taking doesn't really solve any
problem
because you would just give up another
piece that's valuable too
so you shouldn't really go for that uh
bishop of faith is perfectly fine
you should kind of it's more like a
waiting game so your opponent has the
advantage but it's not
super clear that he could come and just
like really whoop you so
let's try to figure out after this
bishop f8 then what
no you don't have a good enough position
to want to sacrifice then you shouldn't
do that
sacrifice should be when you're actually
needed shouldn't just be because you
can't find anything else
i say that because i've done that before
and i thought that sacrifice was just ah
good enough i could get by it and
i got it was a very painful game
all right so yep bishop comes back
to f8 trying to still protect some stuff
it is a little bit painful because most
of my pieces are in the eighth rank
but it does get better i am telling you
also you can see the results here it
does get better
um so now she played b3 because she
wanted to stop my b3s
now rook g6 stopping the ideas with
knight hd so i can free my bishop
and here uh i think she started to play
a little bit inaccurate so she still had
to like try to get the queen out
try to do these she just went to rook d2
and of course bishop c5 that was the
whole idea with rook g6 to stop
the h6 and um she
played rook d1 now black to move what
should we do keep in mind that
this knight is kind of sad over here
your rook is kind of alright your bishop
is great so you should keep that bishop
there
but you should try to still make better
use of
your these three pieces so
how can you make that work
ah queen g8 yep i like that i don't
exactly know what i want to do with this
knights because if
knight c6 uh the problem is take
and you know rift e8's also coming up
that that gotta hurt
so you can't really do much with your
knight at the moment so but you can't
bring this queen to g8
and have some ideas
now you could also threaten bishop f5 as
well because then pawn would have to
take it
because knight can't take it because of
g2 upon
so yep when g8
she played bishop c4 see like bishop c4
was a little bit inaccurate she could
easily play like kingish one to avoid
checks
but she went for bishop c4 now what does
this bishop c4 give us that we didn't
have before
so now with this bishop moved away from
c4
so the ideas of rook d8 are also pretty
valid you got to be careful about that
now what should you do as black
to be completely honest white still does
hold a
pretty decent advantage so you should
still
do um very accurate moves as best as you
can
so yeah your knight gets to escape
exactly
this bishop moving gave your knight in
the square to go back to
so great uh in the game my opponent took
bishop takes a6 now be very careful
you just he just ate she just ate a pawn
so should we take it back
should we let it be or should we take
over here so you have like three
simple um simple ish choices
which one should you go for
all right i see the ideas oh thank you
riley that's very sweet of you to say so
yeah the there's so many different
videos
i feel like that's super great i wish
when i was learning just that or
i was improving my chest um i had this
much
video access all right so i see a lot of
different ideas but
you should take over a fat five because
if you were to take on asics it's
still definitely doable but you kind of
activate your opponent's queen
and this knight here is going to be kind
of hard to remove even if you play this
knight d4
again queen can simply move away um
now you could try to move it there a
little but it's not the same you're
playing very defensive the only way that
you could try and play offensive is to
take over here
take back move the stroke well because
your ripple's under attack
and in the game she played kingish one
now you you see you have some
ideas your rook is a little bit active
your
back rank is saved because of this
knight so you could try and move this
queen somewhere you could try to get a
little bit
more active so how
94 definitely doable
knight d4 is actually the most accurate
move but bringing the queen is another
great move that i went for
too uh well not right away but that's
kind of the idea the problem is if you
went queen g4 right away this knight e4
is kind of
the problem giving you this mini fork
so you have to be very careful with this
but that's not the idea you want to
activate your queen
but right now knight d4 makes more sense
you come up with the knight attack the
queen
and you also block up the rook so
94 is like a triple awesome move
and queen e3 or queen should
my opponent should have brought her
queen somewhere to d3 or e3
and she didn't that was her mistake um
she should have kept the position super
active
like if she played queen e3
also stops my ideas with queen g5 right
so i wouldn't really know what to do
after that maybe i would
still acquire to try to play something
like bishop b6 so maybe i could
move this knight around with that idea
but
i think the problem would just still be
there
uh you could try to play knight h5 but
then again
i could take over here like there's
still that's
um great fight going on but my point
being that
my opponent should have kept her queen
um
active she played queen to e1
now what do you think we should do after
this queen e1
be careful this idea with knight e4
still exists
work
yeah see that's what i was talking about
yourself that
just because the position looks better
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
going to
win it so especially it was kind of
interesting because my opponent
actually had the higher rating and i was
the one
who was kind of um had the worst
position for most of the game i still do
hold the worst position no we shouldn't
knight five does not work you just take
back there's not much
to this rook g2 especially because
there's this knight g3 that kind of
picks up the rock
no knight f5 ain't the way queen g5
would be possible if there wasn't a
knight e4
uh but knight e4 right now unfortunately
still kind of works
well we can do queen f4 and still try to
go for the attack
huh this actually oh that's kind of
funny uh-oh hold on hold on there's a
cool tactic here let me ask
so here black to move what is this cool
tactic
like to move how are you going to win
i forgot i had tea here oh man well
that's sad
that tea is gonna be cold
yeah that's one cold tea
yep rook g2 you got it
and if the king takes that is making
three moves
anybody wants to finish it off
going once going twice before i sell it
to peachy
where is he
yep queen f3 king has to move if you go
to f1
since that square is occupied queen uh
h1 gives checkmate
king g1 brook comes and
voila or voila oh or
so many different mates i love it yeah
so that would be how
rook g2 would be the way to go so
knight c4 actually doesn't really work
as well as i thought but
again bishop c4 is there or um
h3 also works just kicking the rook and
then you would have to move the rug and
then quinn can come to e3
and the queen g5 is still a little bit
um premature
um would rook g8 first
work i'm assuming we are talking about
queen g5
um knight e4 queen over here take
and rook g8 ah no
because there's queen e3
tarik are we talking about this position
or
yeah feel free to correct me if that's
not the position you're talking about
anyways um we could simply try and bring
up the queen
and the rook too that was also pretty
doable
uh but this is the easiest way to go
yeah as long as you had rook g8 check
that was the way to go yeah
yep so in the game i went for bishop b6
just because i didn't want to worry
about this knight
e force oh it was nice having you here
kiss uh bye
well
the problem is that after well not
exactly problem but
after bishop b6 i still hold all of the
same ideas with queen g5
and white should have done like an f3 to
kick this trick a little bit
to mess with my piece's coordination
and then try to bring up bring the
bishop to the fence
and something with like queen g5 and
then again like a knight t2
just try to exchange a little bit to get
rid of some of my
stronger pieces
she didn't she played bishop d3 nothing
really wrong with bishop d3
just that it gives me some chances so
now black to move
what to do
and i have a cat playing with my foot
i kind of like it when he does that but
a little ticklish
oh h5 interesting so nothing exactly but
i like the way you think of bringing
more pieces
um you could try and bring your queen
yeah yourself you got this queen g5
when g5 is the easiest well not easiest
the most practical way to go because
after queen g5 you're gonna just bring
more pieces you're just gonna
bring more um yeah we're also gonna try
and swing the other rook around yep
so i went for this and in the game she
just went for bishop e4
and um bishop e4 rook g8
just doubling tripling up and
just doing my best to bring pressure
and the one thing that i that i remember
was that
in the game i didn't have a clear plan
on how i was going to win
like doing rook g8 i wasn't like okay
rook j8 i want to take on g3 i want to
do this i want to do that
it wasn't like that it was just i had to
improve my pieces
so that i could give myself the chance
to actually
form an attack so it was mainly about
forming an attack
not exactly about finding like that
amazing tactic
because i thought if i do form no hello
no no no no you ain't gonna mess with
people's ears anymore
how's it going buddy so
yeah it wasn't exactly about um
finding that awesome technique because i
knew that
um i should just
develop put my pieces in good places and
the tactic will pop up
by itself right kitty just don't go to
the microphone
good boy um
gotta go the other way microphone is
here good boy go teach instead of me
i love that when happens so
in the game my parents played
what did my opponent play no my
opponents played um
oh yeah he's she started to go after a5s
all right let me try to get the cat
because i gotta
see
who is a good boy sit down
exactly cat counter attack all right
so he is a very demanding individual
yeah so that was kind of her idea she
wanted to push over here but
a1 was a was not a good idea can you
tell me why not
so black to move what do you think is
the best move after rookie one to be
fair i missed it in the game
also because we were in time travel but
still oh
yeah no he's not i am he's gn
he's being a better boy
i don't really care for your tail honey
let's just
come to mama over here good boy
all right so what do you think we should
do as black
ah yourself got it yep rookie four
easiest
just over bearing over low overloaded
pieces
queen defending here queen defending
here this knight can't really move
because i'll have queen takes g2
so yeah that's what i should have done
with rookie 4
but i made the small mistake of not
doing that
wasn't i mean it didn't really change
that much about the game
it seemed it made it a little bit more
um tiny bits longer but
it was kind of the same idea anyways uh
okay so rook takes e4 would have been
the easiest way to win because after
queen takes just queen takes d2
and that's that's something like a full
piece voila
so it was kind of funny that the both of
us missed it
i went for rook h4 because i thought
drake h4 i'm creating some threads
and um in the game she
just pushed for a5 and again i should
have taken over here or taken over there
i played bishop a7 i thought that was
the best way to go about it just bring
your
bishop kitty kitty you gotta sit down
and um then i went
for the cat counter attack
he really wants to be on the camera all
right kitty
move uh-uh good boy
feels like a crocodile walking in front
of the camera
yeah yep i agree black is having a blast
well the thing is if you took it and
then you could oh that would be fun
then you could simply take over on e4
and then again take that back
but it's not exactly as strong as if you
did that turkey 4
immediately so i went for bishop a7
and she played a6 again i could take
rook takes e4
and i didn't so this also should help
you
not feel guilty about missing tactics
uh so i simply went for queen f4 because
i thought queen f4 i'm threatening some
ideas with druk g3
oh she's really being asking for
attention huh
so yeah queen f4 i thought it kind of
works because i want to bring my other
piece and okay she actually did make a
mistake
she kind of cracked under pressure she
should have played something with
h3 here or kg1 but
she went for rook takes d4 which i don't
know why she did that
i understand that this knight is kind of
annoying over here and i could have some
ideas
from left and right with this knight but
there isn't anything
concrete so i don't think she should
have given that up
so she took this rook d4 which was kind
of weird
i took it back and then she just played
a7 and then i took bishop f2 and she
resigned because i also have some nice
g3 eating threats but my whole point was
that
when i started putting pressure for like
5 10 moves
she actually got she kind of broke under
the pressure so that's why i actually
always advise you to put pressure she
broke psychologically i didn't really
have any threats
yeah my position looks kind of scary and
yeah this night is weak that night this
is strong this bishop is good
but i don't really have like a checkmate
rate i don't really have like a tactical
um genius coming up so that's why i
think
she psychologically broke under the
pressure and that's why this is called
chest on psychology because i do want
you guys to be able
to psychologically enjoy chance and
psychologically battle your opponent
and get it done so
yeah that that is one of the games that
i did want to show you today
i don't really have time to show anymore
but you're going to have a lot of me
until january 20th so i will
be showing more of that and no rickish
dude this is very premature your pieces
are not
ready um you could take over here yeah
but
your pieces are not ready you don't have
that you don't have that flow
um the problem is also this pawn
so you can't really just go for it you
have to actually
um kind of let it sit
and you have to keep preparing for it
but yeah
um there is this that's the i think
that's one of the reasons because there
are so many possibilities
she broke under pressure and i didn't so
that's why i won the game
um anyways yeah i hope you guys enjoyed
this game it was a kind of a weird game
because i missed some chances she had a
better position pretty much all game
and she is she was a stronger chess
player she's
still a stronger chess player so i kind
of like that
but all right so um
i hope you enjoyed the rest of your week
i will see you
on thursday uh for some of the classes
and some of the streams so make sure to
tune in for that
twitch and in for our
youtube channel and with that notes i am
going to say goodnight to you and go see
why my cat is super hyped
maybe he sniffed some catnip or
something
anyways i'll see you on thursday have a
good rest of your evening